[Music]
it's a little over the top but i think
it depicts a time in the mob
when they had power like that to send a
message hello my name is john pinissi
i'm a former made member of the lucchese
crime family i also got involved as a a
low associate to the gambino family when
i was very young today we're going to be
looking at mafia scenes and movies and
tv and we're going to judge how real
they are all
right
he said i want
the whole way over
and what's depicted here is a guy
getting what we would call straightened
out
inducted
and
it's inaccurate by the way that they're
kidding around this is a serious
ceremony where there's no joking or
playing around
okay
that's saint peter my family's saint now
was that card burned so may your soul
burn in hell if you betray your friends
in the family there was two members
being made and that is not accurate it
would be one at a time they would bring
one person up into the room
and do the ceremony and then call the
other one up some of the things were
accurate that was said and obviously the
pricking of the finger and the burning
of the saint but
all in all it wasn't
a hundred percent
i don't know if they put it there for
this reason but a lot of italians are
superstitious about birds they don't
even give cards out
uh with birds on it they don't think
it's a good sign but doing really good
this year with the sportsman yeah it's
been good i'm gonna give it to you my
boy it's yours nothing said in stone
of how how long you have to go as an
associate before you become an inductive
member some people have been associates
for 10 15 years five years 10 years
three years when i first got
straightened out it was the at that time
the highest honor to be inducted into a
family and to become a wise guy and to
be treated with that respect looking
back on it now
it was the lowest point of my life it
was an embarrassment
because
basically
everything that i thought the life was
about
was a foss
from a scale from 1 to 10 i'd rate it at
3.
passing around jewelry and that's insane
i don't even i couldn't even answer what
that is about and why they would put
something like that we want to do
business with you michael that's right
we've been together
this was a commission meeting with the
heads of families
new york is chopped up by the five
families and everybody knows their place
and they know who's who
the commission would meet if there was
business to discuss within the families
and decisions to be made
only the people involved in the meeting
would obviously be in the know of where
and when and what time they were meeting
they could take uh
an on the boss a conciliare or even a
captain if they want the different
families intermingle a lot more than
people understand and it's not so
territorial as people think
if they were attempting to hit somebody
it would definitely not be
that flashy it was very hollywood to me
with the helicopter and the machine guns
this would never happen it would be very
low-key and be done quietly
on a scale of one to ten i would rate
this as zero
we're going to try you out with a little
delivery job it's for a
private lottery that we run
the mob is always testing you they may
give you something to do or an
assignment and they want to see how well
you do and carry it out that would be to
just see how you perform overall and
that you stand up
and that you do what you're told to do
there was a saying in in the mob that
there was no rule book giving out
and you had to pick these things up
yourself growing up and being around a
life
gotcha what seems to be the problem
officers was i speeding we'll decide
what you were doing after an illegal
search
in that life you should always assume
that you're being watched and followed
and surveilled that's the fbi's job the
fbi is out there doing their job
trying to make cases so you should
always assume
that they are out there watching you
some people may call it paranoia i call
it self-preservation first and foremost
you shouldn't talk on the phone any at
any time
and you should just watch who you talk
to be very careful who you're speaking
to and what you're speaking about most
things are done and should be done in
person and you should also be leery of
new people that you're meeting i'd
rather plan some felonies oh then we
should meet at our mafia crime
headquarters
[Music]
i think years ago they used to have
storefronts and then the back would be
a club or a place where they would
gather more
more so then than now meetings today
would take place in a restaurant
in our case it was a cigar lounge or at
someone's house or even outside i beg
you i can't make this week's loan
payment
look into your hard drive and open your
mercy file
file not found
shocking is a big part of the income of
the mob money would be lent to anyone it
you know people in desperate need of
money businessmen anyone oh this guy's
an ox he's got oxen like strength hey he
needs a nickname right let's call them
clamps i myself didn't have a nickname
there's names like johnny sideburns that
i speak about a lot guys have names like
sammy meatball sammy clams and it
depends sometimes it's an attribute to
you i'm gonna rate it based on the
future
i'll give it a one
[Music]
i remember seeing the godfather when i
was younger i was very young and not not
in the life i think that a lot of young
guys who watched the godfather all
wanted to be gangsters after watching it
it's a little over the top but i think
it depicts a time in the mob
when they had power like that to send a
message there were some forms of
intimidation verbally that people would
give out or send a message
at times people could get a beating
from the mob
or get their windows broken or something
some kind of sign to tell the person
you know that they're not happy about
something
being that it's the godfather i'll rate
this at a seven
our mole with the russians tells things
a little different
that's a fly if you're being questioned
about something they already know you're
guilty of it as far as punishment goes
it could go from
someone getting a tongue lashing to them
losing their life people in that life
always make a lot of mistakes so there's
always something that you hear of
someone's always in trouble most of the
time you would hear something internally
but sometimes you would hear about
somebody that made a mistake in another
family
that my son is waiting out there in the
car to go to the movies and i ain't
gonna disappoint him
so most of us would try to keep our
personal lives personal away from
that life that we lived i believe most
families assume what the person is doing
with their life but it shouldn't be
talked about with your family some
family members are definitely completely
in the dark about what their either
husband or father or brother or son
are doing as this whole thing unfolded
from the beginning to where i am today
had a big effect on my family i don't
get to see them as often as i like to
they have to go through it with me and
it's it's unfortunate and they suffer
too on a scale of one to ten i would
rate this another zero
he says i must be dreaming
travolta
tried his best to play john gotti
i don't think that really anyone can
play him although the makeup artist had
him look like john gotti a little bit he
tried to get the new york accent right
but it wasn't a hundred percent john
gotti was a copper regime which is a
captain in the family during this time
i had gotten to meet him twice with his
son john jr once in regines in manhattan
second time at a club that they had in
ozone park my job now is to maintain
continuity of leadership
so
i nominate
john gotti so this scene was depicted
obviously after paul castellano gets
killed
and the family has to put in place a new
boss this scene would depict
probably
part of the administration
and captains in the family the
administration being boss on the boss
conciliare
obviously in this scene
the boss is no longer alive i believe it
to be pretty accurate i think that they
would nominate as they did john gotti
and they would
not necessarily take a vote but no one
would
no one would oppose it i second the
motion
so after he's voted in as boss of the
gambino family
it just goes to show you that you don't
have to have the last name that name
came from carlo gambino and it was
passed down to paul castellano
and then taken over by john gotti
paul castellano was put in position
because he was related to carlo gambino
but he was a businessman
john gotti took the position
from being a gangster street guy
two different kinds of bosses i think as
a good boss you need brains and brawn so
you need to be
smart business wise and you need to be a
gangster tough guy in the street i would
rate this scene in eight
let's put down a lot of money
let's play cards
guys like to play cards card games that
i've seen was in cafes and things like
that not like that
i got your message on it from here on
nothing goes down unless i'm involved no
blackjack no dope deals no nothing a
nickel bag gets sold in the park i want
in
if if the mob was gonna deal with a drug
dealer a known drug deal it would more
be on the sneak
and and very low key and quiet it
wouldn't be coming into social clubs
like that it would have to be done on a
sneak because
there is a rule that there's no drug
dealing in their life so that's a rule
that's often broken the other rule that
you're not to go with a maid member's
wife or girl
is broke all the time
you think you're going to live long
enough to spend that money you
hump
i think the violence all the way up to
the 90s
was at a high as compared to today and
that's because of
the cameras and cell phones and
technology so the violence has been
more low-key
i would rate this a two you will be
hearing from me mr scott okay well i can
be very very persistent do your worst
most likely the guy that was selling
insurance was just trying to portray
himself as a street guy he definitely
wasn't what we call a friend in the
street selling insurance all mobsters
have a front sometimes it's selling
insurance sometimes it's waste
management or sanitation for the record
not all italian americans are in the
mafia
the legitimate businesses that they get
into varies and it's really what fits
that person they get involved in a lot
of legitimate businesses it is a front
and it's to kind of throw law
enforcement off too as to where they're
getting their money from i would say 90
of the people in the life are italian
and then you would have probably 10
percent who are non-italians and they're
just associates i would rate this scene
as a five i want to go to college i
can't get called like this
look you take the speakers right at the
same time you say to yourself is the
last time i've ever steal something
it's that simple
it's a low-level
uh thing that he's involved in but he
would gradually graduate to more
sophisticated crimes you start hanging
around with people who bring you around
someone that's involved usually on the
outskirts
and eventually you'll become an
associate
if they want you to
but for the most part it's it's being
young and easily influenced by these
older guys
that's what drew me to the life
being part of this group of
well-respected men that is the law of
getting involved in that life you don't
pick that life i always say that life
picks you i would give this scene a five
a young guy just don't wake up one day
and say hey i'm gonna join the mob by
circumstance you may know somebody who
knows somebody and that's usually the
way it goes as a young man growing up in
both ozone park and howard beach queens
the mob was always around
and i kind of got involved as a low
associate
to the gambino family when i was very
young but by the age of 19 i wind up
getting myself in a lot of trouble i did
17 years in prison
i kind of stood away from the street for
various reasons
for about five years and then was pulled
back into the street and i wind up
becoming
affiliated to the casey family at that
point
and i became a lucasian associate
and i went on to become an inductive
member inside of a year i was inducted
into life
in 2013
and i left in 2018. so i was falsely
accused of cooperating on a case that
just happened within our family and i
know there's no such thing as walking
away from the mob but i basically just
wanted to just try to live my life in
peace they would not stop hunting me
down sending people to come after me and
that was the deciding factor in my
going to the government and cooperating
with the government
there is a list
a very known member in organized crime
according to the fbi that you cannot
talk to meet associated with come in
contact with
this character is obviously out on
parole or on paper as we say and his
lawyers advising him of his stipulations
that he has to follow
and some of those stipulations are not
associating with anyone known in
organized crime anyone would uh would
have convict with a conviction
i mean guys that want to be in their
life today
they get locked up and arrested within
three years
ten guys get pinched nine guys want to
cooperate it's race to the government's
doorstep
when a pinch comes down which means an
arrest
ten guys get pinched
nine guys flip that may be a little high
but it's it's pretty accurate that a lot
of guys turn quickly they want to avoid
going to jail the movie and tv depicts
mafia members as being honorable loyal
and respectful and it's a myth there is
no loyalty there is no honor
there's none of that in today's times
all that has been replaced by
selfishness and greed and people have a
misconception of really what it's about
i would give this scene
a tent i created a blog
it's called sit down news and i
basically cover most mob stories and
created a podcast called the mba and the
button man i want to thank everyone for
watching and if you enjoy the video
please click the link above